we have to make sure that business and
workers have the tools resources and
guidance
and the health and safety standards to
be able to operate safely
the goal is simple to keep businesses
and schools
open safely and for millions of
americans who have lost their jobs
or hours and have had to claim
unemployment
we have to deliver them immediate relief
that includes affordable health care for
millions of people who've lost it
and are in danger of losing it child
care
sick leave family leave so workers don't
have to choose between work
and family relief from rent and student
loans
we need to support small businesses and
entrepreneurs
who form the backbone of the communities
that we live in
that are teetering on the edge you know
there's an urgent need to fund state and
cities
so they can the front line workers on
those jobs can stay in the jobs
you know the founders are pretty smart i
could have gotten this lesson from the
future secretary of the treasury you
know there's a reason why
all the states and localities have to
have a balanced budget but we're allowed
federally
to run a deficit in order to deal with
crises and emergencies that we have in
the past
and we have to keep vital public
services running
we have to give aid to local and state
governments
to make sure they can have law
enforcement officers firefighters
educators
as we did in the recovery act of 2009
and right now the full congress should
come together and pass a robust package
for relief
to address these urgent needs but any
package
passed in a lame duck session is likely
to be at best
just a start my transition team is
already working on
what i'll put forward in the next
congress to address the multiple crises
we're facing
especially our economic and covert
crises
and the team i'm announcing today will
play a critical role in shaping our plan
for action starting on day one and move
fast to revive this economy
they're going to help me help us to help
the country lay out my build back better
plan
a plan that an independent analysis from
moody's a well-respected wall street
firm projected
would create 18.6 million jobs
it's based on a simple proposition
reward
hard work in america not wealth
it's time to invest in infrastructure
clean energy climate change
manufacturing and so much more
that will create millions of good paying
jobs
it's time we address the structural
inequities in our economy that this
pandemic has laid
bare economists call this current
economy
and recovery k-shaped well
like the two lines coming off of a k
some people
some people are seeing their prospects
soar upward while others
are watching their economic prospects
dropped sharply
for those at the top jobs have come back
and their wealth is rising
for example luxury home sales are up
over 40 percent
compared to last year but from those in
the middle and the bottom
it's a downward slide they're left
figuring out how to pay the bills and
put food on the table
almost one in every six renters was
behind in rent payments as of october
let me be clear with this team and
others
we'll add in the weeks ahead that we're
going to create a recovery for everybody
for all we're going to get this economy
moving again
we're going to create jobs raise incomes
reduce drug prices advance racial
equity across the economy and restore
the backbone of this country
the middle class our message to
everybody's struggling right now is this
help is on the way my dad
you've heard me say this before when he
lost his job in scranton
when i was a kid and we eventually moved
the family not far from here in claim on
delaware
just an outskirts of wilmington you used
to say joey
a job is about a lot more than a
paycheck it's about your dignity
it's about respect your place in the
community
it's about being able to look your kid
in the eye and say honey it's gonna be
okay and mean it he also used to say
joey i don't expect the government to
solve my problems
but i do expect him to understand my
problems
this team understands for secretary of
treasury i am really
pleased to be able to nominate janet
yellen
no one is better prepared to deal with
these crisis
i wish it weren't as much of a crisis
future secretary
but she'll be the first treasury
secretary who was also
chair of the federal reserve vice chair
of the federal reserve
and chair of the president's council of
economic advisors
janet is one of the most important
economic thinkers of our time
she has spent her career focused on
unemployment
and the dignity of work which is really
important to me
and to all of us she understands what it
means
to people and their communities when
they have good decent
jobs respect across
being looked at by their neighbors and
be respected it matters a lot to them
and respected across party lines and
around the world
by main street and wall street an
educator
a mentor above all the daughter of a
working class
from a working-class brooklyn
neighborhood who
never forgot where she came from her
husband george
is pretty good too he's won a nobel
prize
but he's the one that married up
[Laughter]
jan will be the first woman to hold this
office
we might have to ask lin-manuel miranda
who wrote the musical about the first
secretary treasury hamilton
to write another musical about the first
woman secretary of the treasury yellen
so that's what i'm working on right now
janet
for director of office of managing the
budget i nominate
near attendant you know i've known near
a long time
a brilliant policy mind with critical
practical experience
across government she was raised by a
single mom
on food stamps an immigrant from india
whose struggle worked hard
and did everything she could for her
daughter to live out the american dream
and nura did just that she understands
the struggles
that millions of americans are facing
and should be the first woman of color
from south asia
from south asia excuse me from south
asia
and uh and i think that uh to lead omb
we also have another one of those women
whose vice president united states
america
and uh so look all being very serious
she'll be in charge of laying out the
budget that will help us control the
virus
and deal with the economic crisis and
build back better but above all
she believes what i believe a budget
should reflect our values again quoting
my dad for real my dad's people would
say joe let me tell you what i value
and they look at them as a high school
educated guy very well read
and they look at me saying don't tell me
what you value show me your budget i'll
tell you what you value
that's what you're going to do for us as
deputy secretary of treasury i nominate
wally audierino wally is uh
you know wally i don't know i tell you
what
senator warren really likes you she
highly recommended you but i wasn't sure
she worried i stole you as well but
thank you for being willing to do this
wally a skilled leader and think around
issues ranging from
macroeconomics to consumer protection
and from national security international
affairs
i've worked with wally during the great
recession that was my excuse to the
senator
saying that's why i wanted to steal you
and i saw him tackle
one big job after another deputy
national security adviser to president
obama
deputy director for the national
economic council
former chief of staff to elizabeth
warren where he helped create the
consumer protection bureau
and financial bureau which has done so
much good
it's designed to protect consumers and
working people from unfair deceptive and
abusive financial practices
and now wally will be the first
african-american ever to hold this post
and the highest ranking african-american
in the treasury department's history
an immigrant from nigeria the son of a
nurse and an elementary school principal
wally understands everything we do is
basically for the people for
families hard-working people to
understand their struggles
and most of all their dreams and he
understands both
and i want to thank you wally for being
willing to do this
for chairperson of council economic
advisors
i nominate notwithstanding she was a
very distinguished professor
at princeton a joke my my children who
went to penn
used to always kid about you know
but cecilia cece rouse one of the most
distinguished economists in the country
an expert on labor economics and race
poverty and education
dean of the princeton school of public
and international affairs
a member of the council of economic
advisers to president obama
advisor to president clinton at the
national economic council
more than that she's a proud daughter
whose mom a school psychologist
encouraged her to
pursue her pursue economics and her dad
one of the country's first
african-american astrophysicists
who dared her to dream she's done both
if confirmed cece will be the first let
me excuse me the fourth
woman to lead the council of national
income of economic advisers
and the first african american ever to
hold that post
and as cea chair she'll serve as a
member of my cabinet as well
as a member of the council of economic
advisors we also appoint jared bernstein
an old friend who's been with me a long
time a brilliant
thinker a quick quick wit with the heart
as big as his head
and a heart he got from his mom an
educator who raised him correctly
a social worker turned economist jared
is one of my closest economic advisors
and friend he served as my chief
economist during the vice presidency
he was there in that foxhole during the
great recession
with the economy on the brink and our
country on our back
i couldn't think of anyone else who i'd
want to be in my side
to face the challenges ahead jared will
be one of the leading voices of my
administration on economic policy
i can always count on him to deliver
straight from the shoulder
as his hero fdr used to say straight
from the shoulder
the one thing i can assure is working
people will always have a voice
with jared and this council as a member
of the council economic advisors i
appoint
heather bousai heather uh thank you for
all the help you had
in the transition team and getting me
here she's
one of the foremost economists working
to make a sure we build
an economy that works for all americans
the daughter of a union family
it's no wonder she believes so deeply in
the idea
that leave no one out leave no one
behind in this economy
during the campaign i relied on our
council on addressing structural
inequities within the economy
and i'll do so again as president
because the center that's one of the
central issues of our time
to this team thank you for accepting the
call to serve again
you're uh to your families and to your
uh thank them for their sacrifices
because it's real sacrifice
we could not do this without you and to
the american people
this team will always be there for you
and your families
this is family oriented team
we got to make sure ordinary people get
a chance to do well because they've
never
when given a chance they've never ever
ever ever let the country down
11 years ago president obama and i
entered office during the great
recession
and implemented the recovery act that
saved us from a great depression
i didn't see the map of america at the
time
nor did he in terms of blue states and
red states
we only saw the united states america we
work with
everyone for everyone and we recovered
and rebuilt
together as one nation vice president
harris and i
will do that all over again with an
outstanding team
they're ready on day one to the united
states senate
i hope those outstanding these
outstanding nominees will receive a
prompt hearing
and that we will be able to work across
the aisle in good faith
and move forward as one country so let's
begin the work
to heal to unite to rebuild an economy
for all americans they deserve and
expect
nothing less thank you may god bless you
and may god protect our troops i now
turn this over to the new team
starting with our next secretary of
treasury
janet yellen again janet thanks for
accepting
appreciate it i think they're going to
clean this off for us here
no i put in my book
thank you mr president-elect and madam
vice president-elect
it's my great honor to have this
opportunity to serve you
and the american people and to join this
incredible economic team
at this moment of great challenge for
our country
mr president-elect when you reflect on
what your father taught you
about how a job is much more than a
paycheck
i hear my own father who raised our
family
in working class brooklyn when he
graduated from medical school during
the great depression he looked for a
home and a place to hang his
shingle near the brooklyn docks
back then bush terminal on the upper new
york bay
was a thriving hub for manufacturing and
transportation
and for the union workers whose
livelihoods depended on them
knowing they didn't have cars my father
found a home near a bus line
he started his family practice in the
basement
while we lived on the floors above
at the end of the day he would talk to
me
my brother and my mom about what work
meant to his patients our friends and
neighbors
especially if they lost a job the
financial problems
the family problems the health problems
the loss of dignity and self-worth
the value of work always stuck with me
so much so that i became an economist
because i was concerned about the toll
of unemployment on people
families and communities
and i've spent my career trying to make
sure people can work
and achieve the dignity and self-worth
that comes with it
mr president-elect i know you've done
the same
i saw that understanding during the last
great recession
and the recovery act that followed
and now we're facing historic crises
again
the pandemic and economic fallout that
together
have caused so much damage for so many
and have had a disproportionate impact
on the most
vulnerable among us lost
lives lost jobs small businesses
struggling to stay alive or closed for
good
so many people struggling to put food on
the table
and pay bills and rent it's an american
tragedy and it's essential that we move
with
urgency inaction will produce
a self-reinforcing downturn causing
yet more devastation and we miss
we risk missing the obligation to
address
deeper structural problems inequality
stagnant wages especially for workers
who lack a college education
communities that have seen industry
disappear
with no good jobs replacing lost ones
racial disparities in pay job
opportunities
housing food security and small business
lending that deny wealth building to
communities
of color gender disparities
that keep women out of the workforce and
keep
our economy from running at full force
it's a convergence of tragedies that is
not only economically unsustainable
but one that betrays our commitment to
giving
every american an equal chance to get
ahead
but i know this team will never give up
that commitment
as you've said before mr president-elect
out of our collective pain as a nation
we will find collective purpose to
control the pandemic
and build our economy back better than
before
to rebuild our infrastructure and create
better jobs
to invest in our workforce to advance
racial equity and make sure the economic
recovery
includes everyone to address the climate
crisis
with american ingenuity and american
jobs
working together with the outstanding
national security and foreign policy
team
you announced last week to help restore
america's global leadership and above
all
we share your belief in the american
dream
of a society where each person with
effort
can rise to their potential and dream
even bigger for their children
i pledge as treasury secretary
to work every day towards rebuilding
that dream for all americans
and to the great public servants of the
treasury department
i look forward to working with you and
wally to rebuild the public trust
to the american people we will be an
institution
that wakes up every morning thinking
about
you your jobs your paychecks
your struggles your hopes your dignity
and your limitless potential thank you
mr president-elect madam vice
president-elect
i'm humbled and honored by the trust
you've placed in me
to work with this talented team on
behalf of the american people
i'm especially proud to work alongside
leaders who understand
that budgets are not abstractions they
are a reflection of our values
they touch our lives in profound ways
and sometimes they make all the
difference
like the vice president-elect's mother
shamala my mother maya
was born in india like so many millions
across every generation she came to
america
to pursue a better life i was raised in
a suburb of boston
a middle-class kid but when i was five
my parents got divorced and my mom was
left on her own
with two young children and without a
job
she faced a choice returned to india
where at a time divorce was stigmatized
and the opportunities for her and her
children would be limited
or keep fighting for her
american dream she stayed
and america came through for her when
times were tough
we relied on food stamps to eat we
relied on section 8 housing vouchers to
pay the rent
we relied on the social net safety net
to get back on our feet
this country gave her a fair shot
to reach the middle class and she made
it work
she got a job as a travel agent and
before long
she was able to buy us our own home in
bedford massachusetts
and eventually see her children off to
college
and beyond i'm here today
thanks to my mother's grit but also
thanks to a country that had faith in us
that invested in her humanity and in
our dreams i'm here today
because of social programs because of
budgetary choices
because of a government that saw my
mother's dignity
and gave her a chance now it
is my profound honor to help shape those
budgets and programs to keep lifting
americans up to pull families back from
the brink
to give everybody the fair chance
my mom got and that every single person
deserves
that's the america maya and shyamala
were drawn to
the america the president-elect and vice
president-elect
are ready to grow i believe so
strongly that our government is meant to
serve all the american people
republicans democrats and independents
alike
all of whom deserve to know their
government has their back
i look forward to working together
alongside the dedicated career
professionals of the omb
to expand possibilities for every
american family and i want to thank my
own wonderful family
my husband ben without whose love and
support
i would simply not be her and our
children alina and jaden
thank you all for this profound
opportunity to serve
mr president-elect madam vice
president-elect
thank you for this profound opportunity
to return to the treasury department
and serve the american people i know
firsthand the president-elect's capacity
to lift our country out of hard times
because i had the privilege of working
with him to help americans recover from
the great recession
in california's inland empire where i
grown up in a working-class neighborhood
the great recession hit us hard we were
one of the foreclosure capitals in the
united states
the pain of this was real for me it
wasn't just numbers in a report
or stories on the nightly news but
neighbors and friends
who lost everything i was proud of the
work i got to do with the consumer
financial protection bureau
protecting american consumers and the
treasury department helping to grow the
us economy
i was proud also of getting a chance to
serve with leaders like the
president-elect
who oversaw the recovery act
implementation
investing in american workers betting on
their resilience and drive
and giving families a chance to get up
off the mat
i believe that's what public service is
all about at its best
giving people a fair shot when they need
it most
offering hope through the dark times and
making sure that our economy works
not just for the wealthy but for the
hard-working people who make it run
those are the lessons i learned from my
parents an elementary school principal
and a nurse
who came to america to build a better
life for me and my siblings
they taught us that we have a
responsibility to serve our community
and the country that gave us so many
opportunities
but i also learned early on how much
more needs to be done
to ensure that everyone has a fair
chance they deserve
i look forward to working with janet
yellen to reduce inequality in this
country and expand the middle class
and make sure that we build an economy
that works for everyone
and as we build back better we must also
remain
laser focused on the treasury
department's critical role protecting
our national security
this includes using our sanctions regime
to hold bad actors accountable
dismantling the financial networks of
terrorist organizations
and others who seek to do us harm and
ensuring our foreign investment policy
protects america's national security
interest
the challenges before us today are
unlike anything we have ever faced
but i know that what the president-elect
so often reminds us of
is true the american people can do
anything
when given a chance and i'm honored to
be a part of this talented team
and to work with them and all the
american people to build an economy that
gives everyone that chance
and turns our nation once again from
crisis to hope
thank you
good afternoon mr president-elect
madam vice president-elect thank you for
this extraordinary opportunity to join
this team
i'm humbled and honored and ready to get
to work for the american people
to be perfectly honest until recently i
did not anticipate i would return to
public service
as every academic knows when you've laid
down roots at a school you love
with incredible students and colleagues
you've grown with
it isn't easy to take a leave it
requires a rare combination of urgency
and opportunity to pull you away
but that rare combination is precisely
what our nation is facing right now
my path as an economist began in my
first year of college
my mother the school psychologist
encouraged me to take a course in
economics
and it happened to coincide with what at
the time was one of the worst spikes in
unemployment since the great depression
it was impossible for me to separate
what we were learning in the classroom
from what i know was going on
to slip through into hardship and
hopelessness
and importantly structural inequities
that have always existed in our economy
are being exacerbated like never before
this is a moment of urgency and
opportunity
unlike any we face in modern times the
urgency of ending
a devastating crisis and the opportunity
to build a better economy in its wake an
economy that works for everyone
brings fulfilling job opportunities and
leaves no one to fall through the cracks
i look forward to working with the
president-elect and vice president-elect
and this amazing entire economic team
to address that urgency and seize that
opportunity
and make our economic system work better
for every american
thank you
good afternoon i'm hard
pressed to find the words to express my
gratitude to the president-elect and
vice president-elect
for the chance to be here today
in thinking about the path that brought
me here a good place to start
is 12 years ago almost to the day
when i met with then vice president
elect biden
at his home not far from here it was
supposed to be a job interview to be his
chief economist
but it quickly turned into a
conversation
about economic justice and fairness
which as
many here know is a common destination
in conversations with the
president-elect
over the years we've continued that
discussion
often it takes the form of some policy
minutiae
sometimes it's me hitting him with far
more graphics than are necessary
or him telling me to stop speaking
economies and start speaking english
you